las vegas it's the newlywed game and i'm
your host guys ted eubanks yeah
he's better
in honor of valentine's day we invited
the spouses of jc and jillian in for
some trivia questions to see who knows
best first we have jillian's husband the
manly the man
kyle
who's here with us today these two have
been married for a whole four months but
don't fret they've been together for
five years get this kyle blew jillian
off for an entire year what
before they got married
before they got together and how
that works i guess
they say love is all about timing
right it
you guys are such a cute couple too and
then these guys jc's wife laura is here
with us jc and laura met in washington
dc back in 2003 because nothing says
love like government
[Laughter]
laura was jc's intern they got
[Laughter]
we're not working you can find them out
on the ranch with their two horses
cagney and lacy i just made that i
apologize contacting barcelona
are you ready couples you guys ready all
right let's see where it works
of course i ask you the questions
you guys and then jillian and jc will
hold up their answers are you ready all
right
who would cast we want to ask you okay
kyle who would cast to play your spouse
in the movie
what do you say kyle
no question i recently just
thought about this and i actually think
it would be miley cyrus oh and your
answer jillian
[Applause]
the young version yeah
all right all right let's move on to jc
and laura okay are you ready yes what is
your spouse's favorite comfort food law
favorite
is
what would your spouse say is their
favorite feature of yours
of yours
and keep it clean
i should say my height
your high jillian your answer
all right laura are you ready yes what
is your spouse's favorite meal that you
cook and let's be nice here and let's
tell the truth
uh-oh
no this is it
um right here
oh
[Applause]
this is almost like the super bowl all
right
here we go all right
what was your spouse wearing on their
first date with you kyle what was your
spouse wearing she was wearing a
beautiful red dress oh my gosh
i got a dress but probably black i
didn't remember
[Applause]
like halfway there
all right great job guys okay we'll move
on to jc and laura all right here you go
if you could take over one household
chore for your spouse forever
what would they want you to do what
household chore would you best i got it
oh here we go close the cabinet
it's not really a chore though
that's not a chore
what would it
be take out the trash
forever take out the trash
look at this look at his face such
intensity
[Applause]
by the way we can start that tonight
happy valentine's day
everybody's mind-melding here i love it
right all right kyle and jillian you
guys ready if your spouse won 5 000
what would they want to spend it on
what do you think five thousand dollars
what would she spend
she would buy a lot of clothes
but i want to almost give you a second
guess i want to go with that
a puppy
[Laughter]
come on out all right here we go okay jc
elora what will your spouse say is the
nicest thing you did in the past week
what was the nicest thing they did in
the past week what do you think laura
he did yes i do
[Music]
[Laughter]
toast in our backyard
lars had some successes at work and i
just wanted a toaster in the backyard on
saturday night
i couldn't pop it open though she had to
open it for me
laura gets ten points on that one
for sure all right kyle and jillian you
guys ready all right you guys are so
cute by the way
thank you if your spouse could have
unlimited access to any store i want
this question
which would it be unlimited access to
any store
what would it be
i'm gonna go with
marshalls
[Applause]
you guys are so cute together it doesn't
matter thank you i'll forgive you i
would have said marshall yeah marshall
you guys fantastic job to both of you
guys thank you so obviously the winners
tonight are all of us
we got something for everyone this is my
show so everybody's winner
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
cheers all right welcome to the newlywed
game thank you so much everybody's the
winner tonight happy valentine's day to
you and happy valentine's day las vegas
cheers